[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
l'hebdo 26 minutes pour un condensé de
l'actualité dans l'est de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 20 décembre
depuis quatre ans le projet de piscine
intercommunale de maurepas et l'encours
a connu de multiples rebondissements
un accord a enfin été trouvé pour la
construction de castanha un centre
aqualudique des lumières sauvage à
thoiry des comptes au château de
rambouillet et de nombreux marchés de
noël l'offre d'animations pendant les
vacances de fin d'année est riche dans
les yvelines
nous en ferons le tour avec notre invité
de la direction attractivité qualité de
vie du département grande manifestation
contre le projet de réforme des
retraites à versailles scène et yvelines
numériques lancée et des idées de
cadeaux made in yvelines nous
reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué la
semaine dans votre département
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine a débattu mardi de ses
orientations budgétaires pour 2020 une
initiative effectuée depuis 2016 et le
projet de fusion des deux départements
le budget 2020 s'inscrit dans la
continuité des années précédentes avec
des orientations vers l'archéologie
préventive
l'adoption en soutenant les services
sociaux et l'entretien et l'exploitation
du réseau routier départemental
au total ce sont 16 3 millions d'euros
de crédits de fonctionnement qui ont été
bottées principalement autour des
infrastructures routières de l'entretien
des routes
nous avons même pas c'est donc une
convention qui est une convention
d'économies pour le contribuable
yvelinois puisque
dans la communauté urbaine de grand
paris seine et oise est un peu
compliquée ce que je veux dire j'ai donc
essayé d'être clair ils ont reçu au
moment de leur création la compétence
voirie
il ya beaucoup de communes rurales ces
communes rurales ont une voirie qui
traditionnellement est entretenu par le
département puis sur les routes
départementales et donc cette communauté
urbaine n'allez quand même pas créer un
organisme pour gérer la voirie que le
département était susceptible de pouvoir
gérer à sa place c'est-à-dire non avec
deux services pour la même mission
donc nous avons ce matin par convention
pris à notre charge la responsabilité de
la voirie à la place de la communauté
urbaine
alors nous on peut financer sa part les
économies d'échelle qu'on réalise en
mettant nos deux départements ensemble
et ça permet du côté de la communauté
urbaine ne pas augmenter les impôts
parce qu'on n'augmente pas la dépense
pour faire cette mission supplémentaire
il aura fallu quatre ans commune de
maurepas est elle en cours pour trouver
un accord pour le contrat de délégation
de service public
il conduira à la construction du centre
aqualudique son nom casta liard un
projet d'envergure qui sera placé au
même endroit que l'ancienne piscine
le centre sera construit sur 28 mois
pour une ouverture prévue en 2022
les détails de mathilde mine est fermée
depuis 2015 est détruite en juin 2019
le centre aqualudique casta lié à verra
le jour à maurepas au printemps 2022
après quatre ans de négociations les
communes de maurepas elancourt ont
approuvé le projet définitif de la
piscine qui sera porté par eiffage et
swim d'où on a vraiment choisi un
candidat qui est eiffage le constructeur
et qui va exploiter l'équipement avec
l'entreprise récréa swing swing d'ô
pendant 25 ans
sur à maurepas et l'idée c'est de
proposer en équipements qui conviennent
à toutes les générations
que ce soit des bébés jusqu'aux seniors
et en passant par l'apprentissage
scolaire et les clubs sportifs
construit au même endroit le centre
aqualudique accueillera cinq bassins en
inox avec différents espaces bien-être
sportif à quoi lâche un projet à coût
total de 24 millions d'euros financés
par le département la région les deux
communes mais aussi des participations
publiques une grande force si dans le
projet c'est que le concessionnaire aura
une obligation d'entretien et de
renouvellement du bâtiment et des
équipements
le concessionnaire l'obligation tous les
ans d'investir pour moins trois cent
mille euros pour entretenir le bâtiment
un équipement qui devra respecter
l'environnement par son architecture et
par les matériaux choisis la pose de la
première pierre est prévue en octobre
2020 pour une ouverture en avril 2022
[Musique]
ce vendredi 20 décembre marque le début
des vacances scolaires deux semaines que
beaucoup passeront en famille au coin du
feu mais aussi à se balader et ça tombe
bien dans les villes on ne pourra pas
s'ennuyer va vous donner plusieurs idées
de sorties avec mon invité julie rey
beau bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
chargé de communication à la direction
attractivité et qualité de vie du
département des yvelines
on va commencer avec les enfants
plusieurs animations leur sont dédiés
évidemment oui tout à fait alors les
sites touristiques du département
redoublent de créativité pour divertir
petits et grands pendant les vacances
scolaires et surtout pendant les
vacances de noël
on peut citer par exemple le château de
rambouillet qui propose pour l'occasion
des reconstitutions historiques avec les
enfants donc des danses de l'époque
costumé avec des costumes qui sont
prêtés aux enfants et des visites
également compté on a également le
palais du roi de rome qui propose lui
des actes liés créatifs autour de la
création de cartes de voeux ou de
décoration de sapins de noël avec des
origamis donc toujours sur le thème de
noël
le musée du jouet quant à lui propose
des visites thématiques pour répondre
aux questions par exemple de pourquoi le
père noël habite au pôle nord ou encore
d'où vient la tradition du sapin de noël
donc voilà des visites à travers
l'histoire des jouets puisqu'on a plus
de 600 jouets anciens au musée du jouet
à poissy way est également le château de
thoiry donc lui qui propose deux choses
pendant les vacances
le festival de lanternes touahri lumière
sauvage dont qui est un parcours musical
et en lumière avec des sculptures
grandiose qui retrace l'odyssée de
l'histoire de la vie en fait un des
dinosaures jusqu'à la renaissance
donc c'est assez féerique et c'est la
deuxième édition encore plus grandiose
que la première et deuxième jouer les
images de la mort ordinaire qui passe ah
oui des spectateurs mais aussi le
château de dampierre et à son père qui a
rouvert ses portes il ya six mois et
pour les fêtes il sera présent nous
recevions son directeur technique on
plateau du 7-8 journel jeudi tout le
week-end prochain là c'est
des activités avec une conteuse qui va
raconter des histoires contemporaines de
père noël de magie de noël fin vraiment
mais vraiment sur l'histoire
contemporaine de ces de cet esprit noël
il ya le père noël évidemment samedi et
dimanche parce que ça on peut pas y
passer avec des solutions de bonbons etc
enfin c'est s'il vient avec sa hotte
remplie en tout cas et puis tout le long
de l'allée des vacances et on a mis à
disposition des carnets de dessins où
les enfants peuvent dessiner avec des
tables sur des petites tables qu'on a
installé fait avec de la récupération
trompe voir on a vraiment fait le côté
vieux environnementales et les
biodiversité et a mis à l'honneur sur
cette forêt magique et du coup les gens
pourront enfin les enfants pourront
repartir avec leurs dessins coloriés
alors et avec les enfants peut aller
aussi au traditionnel patinoire elles
sont nombreuses dans les yvelines
oui alors plusieurs communes des
yvelines jouent le jeu pendant les
périodes des fêtes et ouvre une
patinoire éphémère dans leur centre
ville
on en a encore quatre qui sont ouverts
pendant toutes les vacances scolaires
par exemple versailles les
clayes-sous-bois qui ont la
particularité d'être des patinoires
écologique donc avec un matériau
synthétique pour éviter de faire de
créer de la glace rambouillet
sartrouville et mantes-la-jolie
également qui propose des patinoires
alors pour les sorties en famille vercel
qui promet des activités à son image
royal oui le château de versailles
propose plusieurs animations pendant les
vacances
le parcours du roi chaque année à la
période de entre le 15 et le 30 décembre
c'est un parcours spectacle dans la
galerie des glaces accompagnés de
comédiens de danseurs et de musiciens
baroques pour recréer l'ambiance de
l'époque
donc ça c'est dans la galerie des glaces
et à l'opéra royal du 27 au 31 décembre
on a un spectacle un ballet de presse
blocage qui a un grand chorégraphe
contemporain et qui propose gravité donc
c'est un spectacle son nouveau spectacle
en fait du 27 au 31 avec la
particularité le 31 décembre de terminer
le spectacle par une visite des grands
appartements donc de manière un peu vip
puisque y aura pas le public habituel
et pour terminer un fait un feu
d'artifice pour bien terminer
dans l'année le château de versailles
pour les courses de dernière minute les
et de kaduna les marchés de noël
oui alors tout le mois de décembre voilà
c'est une tradition les yvelines créer
leur marché de noël donc on a plus de
quarante communes qui jouent le jeu le
dernier donc ceux de ce week-end il en
reste plus que huit
mais pas des moindres on a le marché de
magnanville donc c'est à la fois un
marché une patinoire des spectacles et
des animations
donc ça jusqu'au 21 21 train jusqu'à
samedi jumeaux ville donc là c'est la
ferme du logis qui invite d'autres
producteurs et artisans locaux à
découvrir enfin à proposer leurs
produits pour faire leurs courses pour
que les gens puissent faire leurs
courses de noël copains façon locale on
à saint germain les avec pareil un
village de noël une patinoire des
manèges un plein d'animations et à
poissy une particularité c'est qu'on a
carrément une piste de luge grandeur
nature pour petits et grands et un
parcours aventure voit les choses en
grand à poissy et pour les cadeaux des
yvelinois de loisirs créatifs
éco-responsable et encore nostalgique je
vous propose de regarder quelques idées
sélectionnées par notre journaliste
aurélie rose cette année pour remplir sa
hotte le père noël va devoir parcourir
plusieurs kilomètres
premier arrêt saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
c'est ici qu est implanté son taux ce
faire cette société existe depuis plus
de 30 ans elle imagine dans ses locaux
des jeux sensoriels inspiré de la
méthode montessori ou encore des kits de
loisirs créatifs c'est pas uniquement le
petit jeu sur lequel on joue pendant dix
minutes c'est réellement des choses on
va avoir un apprentissage on va avoir
on est vraiment sur le premier le
principe de faire les choses soi-même de
réaliser des choses on est dans un monde
où on va de plus en plus vite c'est
aussi les jeux qui vont prendre leur
temps avec ses boîtes en carton 100%
recyclable sentosphère mise aussi sur
l'écologie une valeur partagée par une
autre société
direction versailles où s'est installée
depuis peu le siège social de nature et
découvertes
depuis sa création en 1990 l'enseigne
s'est spécialisé dans les produits de
bien-être des produits également liés à
la biodiversité
parmi les cadeaux plébiscités cette
année ce nichoirs pour oiseaux ou encore
ces jouets pour les tout petits
et nous avons aussi cette année leur
lancement de notre gamme pour les 0 à 3
ans qui s'appelle gallopin des bois qui
ne gamme devait jouer très vertueuse
parce que nous n'utilisons que du coton
bio pour les enfants nous utilisons du
bois fsc de forêts gérées durablement et
enfin dieu la peinture sans solvant pour
les plus grands nature et découvertes
mise notamment sur une valeur sûre la
lecture un des coups de coeur en livrent
en ce moment c'est le livre vivre avec
la terre de charles hervé gouyer de la
ferme du bec hellouin qui nous apprend
les grands principes de la permaculture
et qui est un très très beau cadeau à
offrir
depuis 2015 la nostalgie à son royaume à
mouiller c'est ici qui est installée la
société naftal gift points comme ce site
internet propose des articles sur le
thème de la nostalgie des jouets des
bonbons qui nous font voyager dans le
temps
3000 produits sont référencés on voit
souvent dans les tendances les gens qui
créent leur coffret avec plein de petits
bonbons et justement ils vont mettre un
jeu d'eau 1 liesse et ouais et vous
faire leur petit coffret pour que les
imagine les personnes retombe en enfance
des coffrets nostalgique proposé entre
30 et 40 euros
alors parlons maintenant de quelque
chose qui m'intéresse particulièrement
la nourriture on peut préparer des repas
locaux oui alors par exemple on a
plusieurs fermes dans le département
parce que c'est un territoire assez
rural
donc si vous cherchez du foie gras qui
quand la base du repas de noël vous
pouvez aller à la ferme du loup
ravissant à base en ville si vous voulez
du saumon vous pouvez aller à la
pisciculture de villette
après on a des fermes qui propose
viandes et volailles comme la ferme de
grandmaison ou la ferme la ferme du
logis dont on a parlé tout à l'heure et
pied plus pour tout ce qui est on à
caviar aussi un le compteur du caviar à
1100 et puis pour tout ce qui est
fromage vous pouvez aller à la ferme de
coubertin par exemple ou à la ferme de
viltain donc on peut faire un dîner
entièrement yvelinois et ont une fois
qu'on a tous à des cours de cuisine
peut-être oui alors on a aussi des
beaucoup de parts de partenaires qui
proposent des cours de cuisine je pense
notamment à
l'atelier de patricia à versailles ou
bien un peu plus original encore
l'atelier l'aide coquine english donc
qui a la particularité comme son nom l
indique d'être un cours entièrement en
anglais donné par une américaine qui a
posé ses valises à verse un nom après la
foulée des achats de noël on peut aussi
avoir besoin de se détendre vous ne
proposez le spa des vaux de cernay
oui c'est un nouveau spa qui vient
d'ouvrir en 2019 et qui est vraiment
dans le domaine dans la forêt de
chevreuse donc on est vraiment en pleine
nature ça permet à un moment de détente
complet et c'est vraiment un bel endroit
à découvrir aux approches de l'abbaye
des vaux de cernay
alors maintenant qu'on est au chaud peu
par les musées expositions concerts
pièces de théâtre vous allez peut-être
des coups de coeur sur les deux semaines
à venir
oui alors en terme de l'exposition par
exemple il y en a une qui termine à la
fin du mois donc le 30 décembre donc
voilà je la congeler recommande avant
que elle ne se termine c'est au musée de
l'hôtel dieu à mantes la jolie et c'est
une exposition sur monsieur book qui est
un dessinateur de bd qui a notamment
fait pas mal de caricaturer 2
voilà qui a reproduit des oeuvres de
grands peintres comme comme monnaie ou
encore mes terres l'unc et voilà qu'ils
proposent on a pas mal de maquettes de
cette personne et c'est vraiment très
intéressant on a toute son histoire
également alors autre coup de coeur
comme c'est la semaine qui précède les
vacances scolaires on a des stagiaires
de troisième à la rédaction
leur ai demandé leurs coups de coeur des
événements des vacances ils me les ont
donnés alors à naomi elle apprécie le
noël féerique du château de breteuil et
ses visites guidées qui ont lieu tous
les jours des vacances scolaires dès
14h30 noël à breteuil ça a commencé dès
le 6 décembre
et ça se poursuit jusqu'au 6 janvier
pour jouer vous en avez parlé ce sont
les illuminations de thouaré qui les
séduisent on peut les observer depuis le
27 octobre et jusqu'au 8 mars
c'est la deuxième année que le zoo
safari organise son festival de
lanternes
quant à matisse il est très intéressé
par le sport et compte bien suivre le
match de 32e de finale de la coupe de
france
rcv fc versailles contre granville dont
on connaît désormais la date ce sera le
4 janvier à 13h à domicile si le club
versailles et l'emportent il égalera son
meilleur résultat dans cette compétition
il était en 16e de finale en 1948 alors
je remercie tous les trois pour cette
élection sortie de d'accord avec julie
oui globalement ça s'est vu merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur notre plateau
alors bien sûr pour les informations
pratiques de tout ce dont on a parlé
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet sortir en yvelines et pour
d'autres idées de sorties loisirs et
culturelles vous avez nos deux magazines
qui sont dédiés le 7-8 culture et le 7-8
loisirs que pour retrouver au replay sur
notre site internet
notre application mobile je vous
remercie je lirai beau d'être venu sur
le plateau bonnes fêtes de fin d'année à
vous merci
or je rappelle vous êtes chargé de
communication à la direction
attractivité qualité de vie du
département des yvelines
maintenant on passe au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et on l'a dit dans quelques jours c'est
noël les sapins sont décorés de
guirlandes électriques les tables
garnies de bougies autant de sources
incendie sur lesquels il faut être
vigilant
les pompiers font de la prévention ces
périodes propices aux accidents nous
recevions lundi le lieutenant colonel
sébastien frémont chef du groupement
prévention du service départemental
d'incendié et de secours des yvelines il
vous donne quelques conseils concernant
votre sapin de noël
la première règle c'est de l'installer
le plus loin possible j'ai envie de dire
d'une cheminée à foyer ouvert lorsqu'il
y en a une dans le salon parce que en
fonction des essences de bois le bois
qui brûle parfois peut produire des
escarbilles enflammé qui sont projetés
en dehors du foyer
et si le sapin se trouve dans un
périmètre relativement réduit
malheureusement c'est escarbilles peut
arriver sur le sapin et le l'enflammé
quasi instantanément à sympa qui brûle
c'est en 10 secondes c'est une torchère
elle rythme cette fin d'année 2010 9 la
grève contre le projet de réforme des
retraites cette semaine à verse à une
manifestation était organisée au départ
de la préfecture le cortège composé de
six cents personnes venues de toutes les
yvelines est passé par le château de
versailles la mairie la gare des
chantiers également les bureaux du medef
78 mais quel ennemi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude les ont suivis
plusieurs mobilisation était organisée
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines contre la
réforme des retraites
amante à poissy ou encore au vésinet
mais le plus grand rassemblement était
ici à verser plus de 350 personnes se
sont réunies devant la préfecture pour
défiler
[Musique]
je suis avec yves de la cfdt de thales
elancourt alors il pourquoi vous
manifester aujourd'hui
ben on manifeste aujourd'hui donc pour
la réforme des retraites
et puis on est présent ici de façon
unitaire ou parce que bayrou semble que
c'est important qu'à un moment on fasse
que le message qui est porté par les
syndicats soient claires et simples pour
les salariés en fait alors la cfdt et on
peut le dire minoritaires ici sur cette
manifestation il ya beaucoup de cgt
est-ce que vous avez est ce que pour
vous c'est important que la cgt soit
représentée dans ce cortège
l'enjeu est supérieur à des idées à des
choses des concurrence inter syndicale
qui n'ont aucun intérêt
en parallèle de la réforme des retraites
les syndicats ont également profité pour
défendre certains métiers alors il ya
quelques postiers qui sont ici un sur
cette manifestation à versailles
pourquoi les postiers se mobilisent
alors les postiers de versailles se
mobilisent aujourd'hui pour leurs
conditions de travail
ils ont une réorganisation interne qui
se passent mal avec des très très grosse
tournée avec plein de petits problèmes
et qui a cumulé fait que passer plus
possible pour distribuer le courrier en
bonne dans de bonnes conditions
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont en grève pour montrer à
l'heure et pour renouer le dialogue avec
leur direction pour que les choses
s'arrangent pour qu'ils puissent
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
pour rendre le service aux usagers
parce que aujourd'hui à des problèmes de
distribution de courrier dans versailles
au départ du cortège les manifestants
étaient finalement plus de 600 à défiler
dans les rues versaillaise
il ya beaucoup de monde ça ne sont pas
absolument pas c'est une volonté je
pense d'essayer de venir dans les
vallées dans les chalets bien dans les
sortir un peu de paris pour les
manifestations et ça m'étonne coque et
beaucoup de monde ce qu'est le moment
nous qui sont concernés qui n'ont pas
forcément réussir à et dans paris qui
voir les preuves de transport est
évidemment donc c'est plutôt bien ça ne
m'étonne pas qu'ils ont tout le monde
que ça
ce matin que la secrétaire général de la
cgt dans les yvelines sonia porot sonia
pour est ce que vous attendiez ce qui
est autant ici à verser on savait que la
colère était très très forte
déjà depuis le 5 décembre mais à voir
autant de monde
aversenq c'est exceptionnel ça fait
plusieurs dizaines d'années que ce
n'était pas arrivé
quel parcours alors on va passer on est
parti de la préfecture en fait devant le
château de versailles qui est fermée
puis cela de nombreux grévistes
on doit passer devant l' agence
régionale de santé jusqu'à les
personnels hospitaliers sont mobilisés
depuis des mois pour des moyens et
pouvoir faire correctement leur travail
le cortège a terminé son chemin au siège
du medef
ici à versailles à l'heure actuelle
aucune autre manifestation des
programmes est ici dans la commune le
département des hauts-de-seine
officiellement adhérents du syndicat
mixte yvelines numériques
ce rapprochement va permettre
d'accélérer la mise en commun des
projets avec pour mission l'éducation le
développement de smart city ou encore la
sécurité les différents acteurs du
projet se sont réunis mardi pour
présenter un nouveau nom seine yvelines
numériques mais aussi une nouvelle
identité graphique
ce nouveau logo il montre
nos deux territoires ont numérisé
et il est intéressant parce qu'il montre
bien que l'apport du territoire alto
séquanais aux yvelines et en superficie
très marginal il est essentiel en termes
de population c'est un doublement de la
population de nos deux départements
c'est plus que doublement de la richesse
puisque les hauts-de-seine sont un
département où l'activité économique les
plus importantes de canines
mais c'est un territoire qui finalement
ne va pas grandir démesurément et qui
donc pourra continuer à être plus proche
de ses habitants on reste dans la haute
technologie et c'est une première à
maurepas un scanner dernière génération
a été inaugurée mardi au centre médical
des pyramides confort pour le patient
diagnostiqué plus précis pour les
professionnels il pourra accueillir une
trentaine de personnes par jour pour des
pathologies pulmonaires des cancers ou
des douleurs abdominales 1 million
d'euros financé par des radiologues de
la région
la ville a été un soutien logistique
pour l'installation les détails tour il
est revenu on a la chance d'avoir des
coûts on appelle ça des coupes
extrêmement fine ce que le un scanner ça
fait à faire des coupes on va co découpé
le corps en en fines tranches
donc là on va arriver sur des coupes de
jusqu'à 0 3 mm donc on a des indications
très précises très fin et un scanner
très rapide donc un poumon par exemple
ça va se faire entre deux et trois
secondes une belle image de soi pour
retrouver un emploi depuis 2012 la
cravate solidaire agi pour favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en recherche d'emploi en
luttant contre les discriminations liées
à l'apparence grâce à un atelier à bord
d'un camion aménagé en dressing devant
la cité des métiers attrape les
demandeurs d'emploi sont coachés manon
moraldo en a suivi derrière ces cintres
jean michel masson habitants de trappes
et et manutentionnaire dans la zone
industrielle
il est actuellement en recherche
d'emploi et fait partie des six
personnes qui sont accompagnés par la
cravate solidaire mobile le but de la
cravate solidaire
lutter contre les discriminations liées
à l'apparence en entretien d'embauché
le but principal c'est de revaloriser
aussi l estime de soi des personnes en
insertion professionnelle
jean-michel explique son projet
professionnel aux bénévoles avant son
coaching en images dans ce camion
aménagé en dressing
ce tract est bien c'est que vous trouvez
une chemise la mission de la coach en
image trouver la tenue idéale pour
jean-michel il faut pas mettre de tichy
la coach en image doit tenir compte des
goûts vestimentaires de jean-michel mais
aussi du poste visé chemise veste
chaussures jean-michel pourra garder
cette tenue professionnelle complète
grâce aux dons perçus par la cravate
solidaire mais dressing de la cravate
solidaire est composé à la fois de dons
qu'ils viennent de particuliers de
collaborateurs d'entreprises est
également de marque de textile
métamorphosé jean michel est ensuite
plongé en situation réelle d'un
entretien d'embauché en recherche
d'emploi il efface un binôme de
responsables en ressources humaines qui
lui donne les clés pour se mettre en
valeur et renvoyer une bonne image lors
de ces futurs entretiens
pour l'instant je reste toujours sur ce
jeu du genre pour voir si ça va être
confirmées ou pas c'est sympa en bas
pendant la chasse à la fin de l'atelier
jean michel repart avec une photo pour
son cv ou les réseaux sociaux
professionnels et surtout un regain de
confiance en lui des images envoyées par
sos gazelle depuis le sénégal véronique
chaplin présidente de l'association
yvelinoise organisé une semaine spéciale
noël à destination des enfants du
sénégal pendant ce mois de décembre
des stars du football comme amara simba
et patrick mboma deux anciens joueurs du
psg ont partagé des moments avec les
enfants et ont réalisé des distributions
de cadeaux et de goûter on arrive à la
fin de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivi on se quitte avec des images de
l'exposition signer en briques l'espace
richaud de versailles propose des
dioramas légaux qui remonte hommage au
7ème art elle est à découvrir jusqu'au
25 janvier
quant à moi je vous donne rendez vous à
la rentrée pour le 7-8 l'hebdo mettez
les soixante dix huit ne vous laisse pas
sans information locale pendant les
vacances le 7-8 journal continue bonnes
vacances
en fait sur tv 78
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]